sciences bonjour et bienvenue dans ce
set up science consacrée aujourd'hui
aussi rennais les siréniens ce sont ces
gros animaux dociles et inoffensif
comprenant les du gong et les lamantins
ils sont trop souvent négligé par nos
livres de biologie en comparaison de
leurs comparses les cétacés
il a louangé cette injustice
pour commencer les siréniens
contrairement aux autres mammifères
marins ne mange pas de poisson ce sont
des végétariens
ils se nourrissent de zostères une
plantes vasculaires aquatique et
attention ce ne sont pas des algues et
si c'était les algues ont 200 m est à
dire plantes vasculaires à côte les
siréniens aussi appelé vaches marines ne
sont pas des cétacés doivent donc être
traités à part ce ne sont pas non plus
des vaches bien entendu il ne s'agit pas
non plus de poissons car bien qu'ils
aient des nageoires les siréniens sont
dotés de poumons et deux mamelles ce qui
fait de petits mammifères marins en fait
les analyses adn indiquent qu'ils
seraient plus proches parents des
éléphants et d irak ce qu'on appelle
aussi dame en irak ce qu'est ce que
c'est c'est un petit animal d'afrique du
nord ou du moyen-orient qui a pour
particularité de ressembler trop
superficiellement un gros rongeur les
siréniens sont communément rassembler
avec les éléphants au sein d'un groupe
appelé technique et ria en effet comme
les éléphants les siréniens ont la
particularité d'avoir leurs yeux si tu
es très en avant du crâne par rapport à
la rangée dentaire ce caractère est
absolument unique par éliminer les
mammifères et pour cause puisqu'il nous
ferait ressembler à ça autre indice de
la parenté entre siréniens éléphants la
présence de s'approcher de la montre
très similaires à ceux visés vont
évidemment si sabots sont inutiles
personne n'a jamais vu un ciré lien
galoper en fait il s'agit d'une relique
de l'époque où leurs ancêtres marché sur
la terre ferme
c'est un peu comme le reste de que sur
lequel vous êtes assis en ce moment et
qui témoigne de notre lointain passé
comme les éléphants les lames entente
aussi un coeur 10 feed ça veut dire à
deux pointes
alors que le doute par exemple n'en a
qu'une les éléphants et les lamantins
sont aussi parmi les rares mammifères à
posséder des mamelles sur le torse et
pas sur le ventre comment dont les
chiens et les chats par exemple les
hommes les plus perspicaces ont sûrement
noté que nos propres femelles sont
également bien pourvu de ce point de vue
et il est possible que cette
particularité anatomique des siréniens
soit à l'origine du fameux mythe des
sirènes les syriens contrairement aux
baleines ne chante pas laisser régner
actuel ne compte que deux genres les du
gong et les lamantins il est possible de
les distinguer par la forme de leur
queue en forme de pêche et le lamentin
alors qu'elle a la même forme que celle
des dauphins celle du groupe ya vendu
crâne est aussi plus courbé l'échiné du
gong que celle d'un mental c'est assez
faible diversité actuelle n'est que le
pâle reflet d'une diversité passé
beaucoup plus foisonnante et il n'ya pas
remonter bien loin puisqu'il ya à peine
trois siècles vivait encore à siréniens
géant nommé la 8e' de stèles
son nom scientifique hydro malice
signifie petite fille de l'eau un nom
assez curieux quand on sait qu'il s'agit
du plus gros site iranien connu cet
animal vivait aux confins du détroit de
béring et détient le triste record de
l'espèce dans l'intervalle de temps
entre la découverte et l'extinction fut
le plus court de toute l'histoire à
peine 30 ans en effet sitôt qu'il fut
découvert cet animal du châssis nous
savions grèce mais ne nous égarons pas
les siréniens donc était autrefois bien
plus diversifiés et si aujourd'hui leur
répartition et quand on est aux
tropiques
exception faite du petit spot polaire un
correspondant à des fins treating de
stellaire merci de cette précision elle
pu autrefois donc bien plus étendue vers
le nord certainement sous l'effet d'un
climat occasionnellement plus chaud sous
ces latitudes où les siréniens
proliférer et c'est notamment le cas en
france ou dans des gisements comme celui
de casser la noue d'anjou par exemple
les fossiles de siréniens se retrouvent
par dizaines depuis leur apparition peu
après l'extinction des grands reptiles
et en particulier celle des reptiles
marins de nombreuses espèces de
siréniens aux formes très différentes
sont apparus et ont pullulé avant de
disparaître
notez aussi que cette impressionnante
diversité de syriens fut à l'époque une
manne pour leurs prédateurs comme par
exemple célèbre requin géant megalodon
bah megalodon quoi alors d'où viennent
les siréniens comme dit plus tôt les
siréniens descendre certainement de
mammifères terrestres
en témoigne la présence de sabots sur
leurs pattes toutefois jusqu'à très
récemment l'anatomie du squelette des
plus anciens siréniens fossiles
demeurées inconnues
par exemple le cas de pro race thomis
primitif les syriens fossile connu
uniquement par un crâne trouvé en
jamaïque et décrit ya plus de cent ans
par le plutôt terrifiant et charles
howell
si ce nom vous dit quelque chose c'est
comme rennes est aussi le célèbre
inventeur du mode dinosaures donc à
l'époque qu'on ne connaissait pas de
sirénia à quatre pattes
toutefois en 2001 darin dunning découvre
et décrit le premier sirénia quatre
pattes venue lui aussi tout droit de
jamaïque peso sirène dunning démontra si
l'évolution des siréniens depuis des
mammifères terrestres et par là même que
la paléontologie peut aussi à sa manière
s'avérer être une science permettant de
faire des prédictions
mais comme toute découverte les
solutions apportent de nouvelles
questions et ici il s'agit d'une
question de taille puisque peso sirène
comme pour aston us viennent tous deux
de jamaïque pendant qu'on sache les
éléphants les irak sont originaires
d'afrique
alors qu'est-ce que sirénia fichiers à
jamais
j'ai bien ma petite idée et la cimade
mais non rassurez vous je plaisante
des découvertes très récente faite par
des chercheurs français ces dernières
années au sénégal et en tunisie
oui mais ça suffit à montrer que des
sirènes ya encore inconnue et très
anciens étaient présents en afrique
peut-être même vive et ils en eau douce
le meilleur reste donc à découvrir en
afrique où certainement de bien plus
beaux fossiles attendent les
paléontologues se stoppe science sur les
sirènes et un seul chef donc bon à
savoir plus nous vous invitons à
consulter les sites dont l'adresse est
dans la description en particulier ne
manquez pas l'article consacré à
l'origine des six régna sur le dino blog
le site du musée d'espéraza
si jamais vous avez un jour l'occasion
vous pouvez toujours visiter un seul
musée de france consacré aux siréniens
fossiles à castellane en haute provence
ainsi que son gisement magnifiquement
prisa merci à tous